welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's continuing
to be a big week for DC fans with the
internet now getting new leaks and plot
details on the upcoming film of birds of
prey throughout this video I'm gonna be
going over everything we know so far
about the DC movie as well as what could
potentially happen in it there will be
heavy spoilers here and no all leaks
like this should be taken with a grain
of salt there are potentially movie
ruining reveals so if you don't want the
film spoiled then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for click
in this video now let's get into our
breakdown of the birds of prey plot
leaks okay so this comes from the DC EU
leaks thread on reddit namely user D RF
d RF - - they posted quite a substantial
leak on the entire movie and this covers
pretty much the full plot the user said
that the film opens on Cassandra Cain
who is poor and lives on the streets
Cain is constantly stealing for a family
and after doing it so long she's pretty
good at it in the film she steals a
diamond from a flamboyant underground
kingpin known as Black Mask who runs
multiple businesses and several
nightclubs Kane is quickly hunted by the
villain and she ends up on the run
eventually while steering this she
encounters Holly Quinn who has recently
split with the Joker and was kicked out
of the house
Holly has a lot of fun with Cassandra
and they go out and buy food for Holly's
hyena during all of this black mask
aka Roman sionis has his goons
constantly after them and this makes for
some big action set-pieces the second
act follows Huntress who is an assassin
that works for Black Mask
she sent out to kill Cassie Kane and
Holly Quinn however on her mission she
learns that Roman is the reason that her
family is dead she goes completely off
and turned on sionis attempting to kill
him and after she fails she too goes on
the run Huntress really wants to kill
black mask and her only shot at doing
this is through Cassandra Cain who she
knows the villain is after Dinah Lance a
retired vigilante and a singer for Roman
he is about the dime
and steps out of retirement in order to
save cassandra from the villain Renee
Montoya notices the rise in killings in
Gotham and decided to do some work on
her own she knows that the GCPD won't be
able to stop a kingpin as big as Roman
and she takes matters into her own hands
since Black Canary Huntress and Renee
are all after the same girl they all
come together at some point and Roman
gets a mask but it only covers half of
his face and the mask itself is an art
piece for the final act the birds of
prey is formed and at this point they
have a lot more of Romans goons after
them Cassandra Cain ends up being
retrieved by Roman and the birds of prey
and Renee Montoya have to join together
in order to get her back this is
apparently the reshoots that they were
doing and it just flashes out the plot a
bit more in the finale Roman is defeated
but he's set up for a potential sequel
and ending twist is that the whole fuss
about the diamond was that it is
actually a gay sex tape that has Romans
picks on it the user also posted a list
of other notable leaks including the
kill count in this movie is ridiculous
the Bo P has no problem killing at all
Huntress is very sarcastic similar to
Jessica Jones and she gets her mask and
costume in the film most of the birds of
prey have worked for Roman or have known
him in some other way and most
importantly black mask kind of runs
everything in Gotham Roman is entirely
cold-blooded and has no remorse for
anyone he happily kills women men and
children in the movie all in his quest
to attain power and that concludes all
of the plot leaks that we have the user
does say that the movie is bonkers and
chaotic but that it's a lot of fun now
personally if these leaks do turn out to
be true I think the movie sounds pretty
standard and almost just sort of like a
rehash of the Suicide Squad with a new
lick of paint whilst I did enjoy that
film as a guilty pleasure I'm not sure
that I'm open to sitting through another
version of it which revolves around
tracking down a gay sex tape I'm not
homophobic or anything I just think it
seems like a really weird plot device
for a comic book movie and if it was a
straight sex tape then yeah I definitely
think the same thing as well I think
that if this is the real storyline of
the film
then DC they just need to sort out their
identity crisis excuse the pun they're
comic-book fans and decide what kind of
movies they want to make we have seen at
the Joker and I've going Batman movies
are going off in completely new
directions and this kind of seems to be
undoing all of that instead focusing on
some pretty dumb elements I mean it's
great that we are getting the critically
acclaimed Joker film but then to
constantly be rehashing things that a
lot of fans hated such as the squad's
outing seems I don't know like a waste
of time really now as always this is
purely down to the execution of the film
and if the tone about the sex tape is
right then this could easily be up there
with the rest of the better films in the
DC slate potentially potentially I must
must stress that as of now though this
hasn't really got me excited for the
movie and if anything I'm kind of
thinking that this would be a dud nor
remains to be seen but personally I
would have thought that the company
would have been focused on that new
direction rather than constantly
reminding us of some of its perceived
films now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this and if you
disagree with me or not
let me know if this is made you more
excited for the film or if you are
expecting better comment below as always
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my full breakdown of the casting
news that jeffrey wright will be
Commissioner Gordon in the upcoming
Batman movie I go over the announcement
and give my thoughts on it so make sure
you check it out after this if you want
something else to watch if you want to
come chat to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books that make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and topics so
hopefully I see you over there after
this also just want to let you know that
we're currently giving away spider-man
far from home on blu-ray and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on birds-of-prey in
the comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random
looked over the 15 so best of luck to
everyone he takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]